salve youtubers e benvenuti alla prima
recensione dell'anno quello che sto per
noi no scusate non riesco neanche a fare
finta di essere contento perché la prima
recensione dell'anno perché purtroppo è
la prima recensione dell'anno
avete letto il dietro si parentesi tonde
qualcuno la marcia indietro no manco io
prima di due settimane fa ne ero a
conoscenza un porcaio no vabbè ci
arriveremo se arriveremo con camion e
li ringrazio bar duck 909 per avermi
fatto conoscere questo caro bardach se
ti dovessi trovare per strada stata
quello che ti falcio all'istante so bene
che altro dirvi parte che gli sembra ci
sia solo la zona hanno messo da poco
è un film del 2006
2005 2006 non lo sanno neanche si dice
in my movies dice che del 2006 in altri
siti dice che del 2005 comunque 2005
2006 non fa nessuna differenza
sceglietelo voi il motivo per cui
questo film fa schifo perché duro no non
quarto ma è molto meglio guardare una
piastrella per un'ora un quarto che
questo film volevo avvisarvi che io ho
preso questa versione qui ed è l'unica
esistente sulla faccia della terra
perché appena l'hanno fatto l'hanno
visto mio dio l'hanno bruciato nelle
numero 5
il cast
ho qui la pagina di movieplayer.it che è
l'unica ho trovato con il cast vi elenco
il cast per farvi capire
partiamo con calma
raffaella deciso
sì ma raffaella deciso
raffaella deciso ok
giucas casella
solo quando ve lo dico io solo quando ve
lo dico io ve lo ricordate si giucas
casella e no non sto scherzando
veramente se poi lo vede veramente
il pop e lo so chi sia va bene solo per
roberta bonacci
no non so chi sia non importante eva
henger
eva henger
no non c'è neanche una scena di nudo
faceva i no neanche quello
antonio zequila er mutanda antonio
zequila
era mutande quello che ha partecipato
all'isola dei famosi non chiedetemi come
faccio a saperlo c'era la sua immagine
ovunque al cha over
patrizia de blank la contessa de blanc
nel ruolo di se stessa come se non
bastasse se già non saperci tar e in più
fa anche se stessa che non rompe con
siamo perdere
karim capuano
chi cacchio è karim capuano punto kit
è un ex tronista di uomini e donne
ora
che cazzo vuol dire se non ex tronista
di uomini e donne ex tronista cioè
essere tronista è un lavoro che non lo
fai più sei un ex tronista di uomini e
donne c'è lui non era un metalmeccanico
un operaio che adesso non lo fa più che
ne sono andato in cassa integrazione
allora dici è un ex operaio un ex
metalmeccanico un ex tronista di uomini
e done cioè i primissimi donne non fanno
nulla non puoi essere ex di qualcosa che
non è nulla no perché io non voglio più
il vetro c'è karim capuano
che cazzo
numero 4 che sta succedendo
si arriva ad un certo punto del film
dove inizia la sfilata diciamo torno
alla fine siamo seconda metà fine dove
succede qualcosa di stranissimo cela la
tua mente o si spiaccica contro una
parete di glassa e non capisci più
niente c'è aria di inizia la sfilata ed
entra flavia vento flavia vento fra via
ten perché film perché flavia vento che
centra flavia vento ma se buttiamoci
tutta la merda inutile dentro sé tutta
la gente che passa famoso un evento in
realtà trascini dentro si fa vuoi fare
l'aspirazione a che facciamo fare
esperienza sia molto se non lo so e
brindiamo chiunque prendete me non so
prendiamo chiunque ma non lo fa teso
inquadrano giro un'inquadratura mln la
giuria della bella sfilata magari c'è
marco columbro e volevo salutare la
giuria presieduta da volti noti dello
spettacolo e soprattutto sarà
cosa
cosa perché no non può ma non puoi
buttarci dentro tutto quello che vuoi
mettiamoci bud spencer e tele serali ma
semmai mettiamoci qualsiasi cosa tanto
dice non puoi farlo
in casa del cazzo questo marco columbro
che ci fa lì c'è marco columbro è
sparito dalla circolazione la vita marco
columbro e viene ficcato a forza del
film chiamato parentesi donne dio un dio
e questo punto dirvi che dice che sta
succedendo cioè se spaesato marco
columbro fa il momento che centro poi
durano un secondo fumo e spariscono c'è
certo devo per entrare dico mi faccio
pagare dicono il mio nome poi vado via
roma
sono sclerato perché non riesco a capire
non riesco a concepire eva henger karim
capuano
proprio zecchi rakic vabbè andiamo
avanti ma
numero 3
recitazione
raramente ho visto livelli così bassi di
recitazione ma 12 a una recitazione
pessima ma quando dici che ha una
recitazione per il sì ma è perché ha una
recitazione che poi serve lo brutta
quella recitazione non esiste non esiste
raffaella lecciso non è un attrice come
siccome intorno zecchina così come
giucas casella quando te lo dico io
coresi come karim capuano hanno preso
quello del ex tronista che vuol dire
quindi guardatevi qualche scena è
allucinante
io
e lui ne casa è stato per te amore ma
mette anche dire queste stronzate tv del
film guarda mamma mia come te ne prendi
perdonami craig guarda che sono cambiate
sono tornata per restare no scordati non
li così facili come credi ti ho io me la
prendevo tanto con alberto tomba ma qua
ok no non so neanche come commentare
dopo guardi le scene rimane basito il
tuo cervello con la dalle orecchie
perché non ce la fa più neanche lui sa
reggere sta schifezza e rimane così
atterrito io non so come convinta che le
stesse neve le faccio vedere basta
numero due
la storia ecco qui andiamo man mano a
fondo e fate io faccio una classifica
perché passate dalle cose meno rende
così la storia c'è io ve la devo leggere
perché quando guardavo il film con il
mio amico stavamo soffocando dalle
risate e non riuscivamo a capire più
niente nella storia della vela leggo
una da sempre da movieplayer.it una
piccola ed intensa parentesi estiva
ricca di equivoci segreti sogni e conti
con il passato che cambierà del tutto la
vita i protagonisti della storia asi
arabo film totalmente diverso solo erano
solo relazioni dettate a caso concede
cuffee ingenti senza figli donne che
ritornano dal passato
recitazione orrende perché quella non
mancava mai nelle scene matteo e voi
divertire assegni getti la spugna di
cibo io lo guardo giusto perché mancano
dieci minuti e vabbè
mettiamoci anche sti dieci minuti
diciamo di aver visto parentesi tonde ma
credetemi può succedere qualsiasi cosa
in dieci minuti ho detto magari finisce
con un'invasione del nemico ficcata con
un'esplosione nucleare è diventato tutto
la che in sciro post atomico di
fighissimo no set due immaginate di
tutto quello che avete visto prima è
stato completamente inutile perché alla
fine si scopre che è tutto un sogno
vanessa guardami guarda a nesta guarda
negli occhi
o
perché queste cose non si possono fare
ci sono alcuni cliché
allucinanti che tu nei film non puoi
mettere non puoi mettermi che è stato
tutto un sogno
c'è tutto quello che ho visto un'ora e
un quarto di film completamente inutile
no
no perché io sclero cemiss arredare
lavora veramente fissate dalla bocca e
ti manda a fare in culo perché veramente
mi esce da dentro
ma ok è certo la spugna per la seconda
volta la recensione la finisco qui al
secondo posto no no no no no no no no
non mettete il primo punto non fate
girare i numeri non voglio saperne più
niente io me ne vado no no no no no no
non voglio no no no no no le battute
le battute
le battute in questo film oh mio dio le
battute in questo film
c'è la prima battuta arriva dopo 20
secondi il primo dialogo che c'è e
tenetevi alla sedia e respirate tenetevi
alla sedia e vola faccio vedere questa è
il primo dialogo c'è la prima battuta
del film
ma se io illustro giunti loosli frank
sinatra l'avete capita sì io mi nutro
tutti inutili frank sinatra io mi nutro
tutti nutri frank sinatra
questa è una delle peggiori e posso
dirlo con il cuore battute che io abbia
mai sentito in vita mia
uno che si crede simpatico con i giochi
di parole dovrebbe essere legato alla
sedia di saw l'enigmista quella con la
trappola d'orsi girata al contrario
quella che ha tempo fa su rai e trancia
tutto una qui in testa una sulle palle
mi fermo qui perché veramente super
vomitare
non ce la faccio io vi ringrazio per
tutto il supporto che